c'est le gravillon vient de mourir ce
matin quelle est votre réaction
celui effondré ça aide quand vous ne
prenez jamais parié des malades d'un
grand bonhomme pour vous immense part ça
brille en est mort ah non c'est pas
possible
marcel gravillons c'est pas vrai
monsieur on apprend à l'instant la mort
de marcel gravillons quelle est votre
réaction
mars grémillon nom marcel gravillons je
connais pas geof footballeurs qui jouent
aux échecs honte de vous dire que je ne
connais pas un point c'est tout c'est
pas grave on fait comme si vous
connaissiez on a besoin dans l'action
vous me dites oh la la quel dommage que
le grand bonhomme l'on peut dire c'est
un grand homme si je le connais pas jean
belin parce que tout le monde aura son
heure
philosophe footballeurs qui jouent aux
échecs donc il était assez complet quand
même ok il était complet pour être
complet celle des complets messieurs
nous apprenons à l'instant la
disparition de marcel gravillons quelle
est votre réaction
écoutez si c'est une personne connue
doux et tout ça que cela vous affecte je
participe à votre votre open
et vous personnellement c'est quelqu'un
qui vous a marqué non mais si puisque je
vous dis de dire oui monsieur je ne
dirais pas oui parce que je suis têtu je
suis pas breton mais je suis têtu et oui
mais vous avez bruit quand je veux dire
oui mais vous gifle et vous aurez gagné
quoi monsieur nous on a besoin de faire
un sujet web et donc malgré mes 70
balais je vais pas me laisser giflé
comme ça un bon alors on va on va se
calmer on va la faire
monsieur quelle est votre réaction ma
réaction avait elle est tout à fait
neutre maïs collet l'a perçue très
peinés
je ne va pas dire je suis très peiné si
monsieur ses objectifs c'est
l'information
moi ça ça m'intéresse voilà c'est bien
allez je vous laisse à votre votre
émotion monsieur ces personnes tristes
une de plus qui ne veut pas témoigner
encore sous le choc
le réveillon viennent mourir qui est un
menteur de l'abat jour madame vous avez
une réaction de son érosion
vous avez un traitement donc nous avons
enfin trouvé un témoignage d'une jeune
femme qui admirait marcel gravillons
cette crapule qui a dénoncé rappelons le
de 1800 résistant en 43 un homme que
personne ne regrettera ce qu'on appelle
en termes de métiers une ordure merci
mademoiselle vous m'avez pas dit que
c'est un collabo moi je vous ai dit
d'emblée que je connais je ne savais pas
qui c'était donc je suis désolé vous
êtes foutu de moi quand tu dors chacun
ses goûts vos chacun ses goûts je
connais pas le type vous m'avez fait
vous m'avez dit de dire oui oui c'est
l'information fait toujours comme ça ne
commence à brûler journal je peux pas te
fait pas déjà juger quelqu'un je connais
pas vous l'avez fait vous l'admirer
placez-vous qui va qui m'avait dit de
répondre oui moi tu as mais j'ai quatre
témoins
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
dit tu es abonné vous mettez un pouce
bleus